- It's Gabrielle Union!
- Hi, hi, how is everyone?
How are you Drew?
- Oh Gabrielle,
I feel like I'm getting
to know you so well
through reading your book.
- Oh, you're learning way too much.
(laughter)
- Oh, by the way, I was
watching all the press,
for "Bring It On: 20th Anniversary".
And is it true?
- It's true.
- Oh my God, I mean, I can't
even tell you, all day long,
me and my girls sing the Toros song.
I'm so excited.
My daughters are going to freak out
that I was with you today.
And all night long we're
gonna be (clapping).
♪ Brr it's cold in here ♪
♪ There must be some
Toros in the atmosphere ♪
♪ I said, o-ee-o-ee-o, ice, ice ice ♪
Oh my God it's so good!
Sorry I had to, sorry.
(laughing)
- It's okay, it's okay. You're not alone.
- I'm sure you must
get that, all the time.
- All the time.
And I don't remember the cheer,
so that's like, thank you.
- There's a video that went
viral of you and Kaavia.
She's upset about a bag,
and she started kicking it.
Sometimes I literally think
my kids are the only one
who are behaving this way,
and it does make you feel like
you're alone on an island.
So there's not a Hallmark
greeting card for relief
and there should be 'cause
I think we all feel relieved
when we see other parents
going through the same thing.
- Yes!
I started the motherhood
journey a little later
in the game, I'm a little
longer in the tooth
than I had imagined, when I was coming up.
I assumed I would be a young mom,
not a mom with lower
back pain and you know?
Who liked to listen to
Earth, Wind and Fire.
So it's a little different but,
every day is like new surprise.
Like watching her with that backpack,
so all of us, my little
sister moved during Covid,
to help us with Kaav, and
we have this huge village,
but we're just watching
her and we're like,
where is she getting this from.
We're all relatively peaceful,
zen masters in this house,
so watching her, the rage.
Like we call it the ragey-rage,
like where did that even come from?
That just came from inside
of this little person.
- Oh, I'm reading your book right now
and you had fire in
you when you were young
and like, I think you
are probably zen now,
because you took a whole
lifetime to get there.
I love also your romantic,
beautiful love story with Dwayne.
Listen relationship goals,
you know, we all need it.
How is it parenting with him?
- You know with each kid,
it's a little different.
Like, we definitely had to get
out of the one-size-fits-all
parenting rather quickly.
So I'm a stepmom to four kids
and we share Kaav together
and my husband started
his parenting journey
you know, pretty young,
and so I think over time
and then since we've been married,
we together have come into
a different parenting style.
So, with Kaav, we're very
much on the same page,
same with Zaya, but like
with the 18-year olds,
I am like this psychotic, overbearing,
"What are you doing now?" kind of parent,
and my husband's like "Meh, whatever."
They're gonna figure it out and I'm like,
"But we can help them figure it out,
"if we just hover over them!"
So, I'm learning to kind of let go.
They're both away at school
and it's really, really hard for me.
I probably talk to them
more now that they're gone
out of the house, than when we
were all under the same roof.
It's terrifying, for me, having them be
across the country by
themselves on these new journeys
and we're not right there,
and it's driving me crazy.
And then the girl situation, I,
I've become somebody
that I hated dealing with
when I was dating as a teen, I'm that mom.
- I look forward to my
daughter's date showing up
where I have like, a
sawed-off weapon, an NDA,
a chastity belt and a
taser, so I hear you.
One thing, I have to mention
is I cannot stop eating these.
These are Bitsy's, your amazing new snack.
And by the way, very important,
they are school-safe,
which I really wanna press upon,
because that's such a
concern of a lot of parents.
They are so delicious and amazing,
I've Googled, you can find
them at Amazon and Whole Foods
and any other vendors,
we'll put it on the website.
Parents, you're not gonna
believe how incredible these are.
And we have more to talk
about with Gabrielle
that she is contributing and producing
and putting out into
the world, product wise.
She is making the world
a more delicious and beautiful place.
(upbeat music)